you remember the Golem game I played it
here on this channel and it was not
great performance problems aside it just
has a lot of really weird gameplay
choices and choosing Golem as the
character to delete a game is just a
strange choice in and of itself this is
also the matter of how he looks but it
is what it is well the games developers
actually shut down but not before they
had to issue an apology the studio got
most of their experience working on
pointand click games which this is not
so it does kind of inform some of the
weird design choices and then issued a
really strange apology that also
featured hos it said we would like to
sincerely apologize for the
underwhelming experience many of you
have had with the Lord of the Ring golum
not even Lord of the Rings upon its
release we acknowledge and deeply regret
that the game did not meet the
expectations we set for ourselves or for
our dedicated Community please accept
our sincere apologies for any
disappointment this may have caused a
new report from German investigation
Outlet game 2 claims that they actually
wrote the apology using chat GPT they
also reported on a bunch of culture
issues including Crunch and burnout
which of course can lead to Bad video
games